مع تقدم الناس في السن ، يمكن أن يؤدي ما كان في يوم من الأيام
انسكابًا بسيطًا إلى مشاكل أكثر خطورة
لمنع السقوط من البدء
بتدريب القوة ، وهو أمر
مهم بشكل خاص للجزء السفلي من الجسم حيث
تسارع فقدان العضلات بعد سن السبعين ،
كما أن السلامة المنزلية مهمة أيضًا
وفقًا للمعهد الوطني للشيخوخة  تحدث 6
من أصل 10 شلالات في المنزل لخلق
بيئة خالية من السقوط ، تأكد من أن جميع
مناطق المنزل مضاءة جيدًا لتقليل
الفوضى وتأمين أو إزالة سجاد المناطق الصغيرة
التي قد يكون من السهل التعثر عليها
أخيرًا كن على دراية بالآثار الجانبية
للأدوية.  يمكن أن يسبب الدوخة
والارتباك والنعاس الذي يمكن أن
يزيد من خطر تعرض الشخص للسقوط من
المهم مراجعة الأدوية بانتظام مع الطبيب ولا تتوقف أبدًا عن
تناول الدواء أو تقلل الجرعة دون
التحدث إليهم أولاً في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا بريت كونواي